hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university calm
thank you and enjoy so next up in stage
two we're going to be converting
mevalonate into isopentenyl
pyrophosphate or IPP stage 2 IPP
synthesis so we're going to start off
here with melville on 8 and we're going
to turn it into 5 phospho level on 8
which basically just has a phosphate
group attached to this this OAH group at
the 5 carbon here so that's going to
that phosphate is coming from an ATP so
an ATP going to an ADP here and that is
going to be catalyzed by a kinase right
because kinase is add phosphates from
ATP or gtp to whatever it is they're
adding it to and in this case it's
adding it to methyl on it so it's bevel
on 8 kinase that should make some sense
there once we have that we're going to
take 5 phosphate level on it and turn it
into 5 pyro fossil and roll on 8 which
basically just has another phosphate
group attached there at that 5 carbon so
again we're going to have an investment
of ATP ATP comes in 88 DP comes off and
another kinase will be catalyzing this
so in this case though it's phospho
melville on 8 kinase because it's asked
acting on a phospho metal on 8 so far so
good make some sense not too bad next up
we have five pyrophosphate villain eight
and we're going to convert it to three
phospho five pyrophosphate level on it
which basically just has a phosphate
group attached to the do age group on
the third carbon and so again another
phosphate will be coming from from an
ATP and in this case though the enzyme
catalyzing this reaction has a little
bit of a confusing name level on 8 5
pyrophosphate decarboxylase the methyl
on 8 5 pyrophosphate part makes sense
because we're talking about 5
pyrophosphate level on 8 that it's
acting on but the decarboxylase far
doesn't make sense until you look at
this next step because this enzyme kind
of catalyzes both of these steps at once
add that phosphate and also catalyzes a
decarboxylation step where we will
actually lose this carboxyl group here
as a carbon dioxide
so here we make this 3 this 3 phospho 5
pyro fossil metal on 8 and then we're
going to get rid of that carboxyl group
as carbon dioxide as well as we're going
to lose that the phosphate group
fostered by the third carbon and then we
have our product here the isopentenyl
pyrophosphate which is IPP so now that
we have this that's basically that's
basically it right we've made IPP
however IPP is not the only molecule
that we'll need before we can actually
get a sage 3 this IPP needs to be
converted or at least some of them need
to be converted to dimethyl a low-power
pyrophosphate board or DMA PP and that's
because this DMA PP is actually going to
be necessary for the condensation
reactions that follow so it's not just
IPP that's going to be this 5 carbon
unit that we're going to piece together
to make squalene in stage 3 it's not the
only isoprene unit so these guys are
going to be our two different isoprene
units and isoprene of course looks like
this it's a 5 carbon unit that is that
we're gonna basically going to use to
link together to make our squalene and
the reaction that that isomerize this is
IPP to DM a PP is very cleverly named
IPP isomerase so once we have IPP and
DMA BP we can have the the condensation
reactions that follow to give us
squalene in stage 3 speaking of which
I'll hopefully see you there in the next
video thank you for watching thanks for
watching and be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and share the video if any one
new thing might find it helpful thanks
happy studying